Noah Sanders.
Here for the job interview.
Please take a seat.
Mr. Weinstein will see you next.
[lounge music]
♪ ♪
Job interviews, huh?
Never fun.
Okay, just...
I get it.
Stay focused.
Cool.
Cool, cool, cool, cool,
cool, cool, cool, cool.
[clicks tongue]
[laughter]
Oh.
- Yeah.
- Whoo-hoo!
That was a big laugh.
[exhales]
(Weinstein)
Oh, no!
- I did it!
- No, you didn't!
- I did it.
- [laughter]
Jeez.
Is this a job interview
or The Carol Burnett Show?
- You know what I mean?
- [laughter]
Oh, sir, sir, sir.
- Oh, my God, that is too rich.
- Oh, well.
Thanks so much
for coming in, Adam.
Of course,
and you better stay away
from that Chinese food there.
Oh, my God,
you got that right.
That's done--it's done a number
on my stomach.
- [martial arts shouts]
- [grunting]
Here's your fortune.
You're gonna be sick
in a half hour.
[laughter]
Oh, my gosh,
what an absolute delight, Adam.
It's been great, and--can I
tell you something real quick?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I don't even care
if I get this job
because I know
I've made a friend for life.
What a terrific attitude.
What a great goddamn attitude.
Yup.
You son of a gun.
You know what?
Right quick, before you leave,
I want to give you something.
No, sir,
I can't take any more gifts.
This whole thing
has been a gift.
My brother passed away.
[somber music]
21 years ago.
Wow.
We were estranged,
and he became ill,
and he gave this to me
as a peace offering.
Ohh.
And then one day
when we were on the ocean,
he fell overboard on a boat
very much like this one
and died.
I saw him struggling
all the way
as a riptide
just pulled him down.
That bitch ocean.
Would you please accept this
as a--as a token
of my gratitude for you
bringing joy back into my life?
Under any other circumstance,
I would refuse,
but I will accept
this gift today
because I know
how much it means to you.
So I will.
Thank you.
Ahoy, matey.
[both laugh]
[laughter]
How is that funny?
Bernadette.
- Are you hearing any of this?
- Oh, my God.
This guy. How do you keep
a straight face all day?
[laughter]
She's--isn't she sweet?
Sweeter than pie.
Oh, my God.
God damn it,
I love your fucking energy.
Well,
what can I say, sir?
I am solar powered.
[screaming laughter]
[continues laughing]
Really?
You like--
you like that one, huh?
Oh, thanks so much, Adam.
Terrific.
[laughs]
Best interview I've ever been
a part of in my entire life.
Okay, who's next?
You? Ready?
Let's go. Chop-chop.
Here we go.
[clapping]
Come on, let's go.
Okay.
Hoo-hoo!
Hoo!
Requesting permission
to come on board, sir.
Hi, Noah Sanders the name.
Sorry to hear
about your brother.
Maybe we could get
some Chinese food after this?
- [clicks tongue]
- All right. All right.
Okay, take it easy.
Jeez, settle down, turbo.